said well tomorrow will mark 40 years
since one of the worst disasters in
nevada history
a deadly fire at the former mgm grand
hotel and casino
killed 87 people and it injured hundreds
more
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
sits down with the people who not only
help fight the flames
but also those who survived
these are gaming chips that were melted
together
mementos and memories these are pictures
of
both the building the fire
charlie lombardo shares snapshots
showing the devastation of the deadly
mgm grand fire
40 years ago this is a crap table this
was the casino cage
just burned just just burned
reminders of the morning the former slot
mechanic survived
it was a fireball video from that day
shows plumes of smoke rising from the
building
the aftermath of an electrical fire in
the deli restaurant
it spread through the casino which did
not have sprinklers
lombardo recalls crawling on his hands
and knees to get out
after hearing an overhead announcement
to evacuate the building
i went maybe six eight feet i thought
this is nuts
i turned around and went back because it
was clear behind me
[Applause]
he eventually found an exit but not
before warning colleagues in a coin
counting room to get out
i want pounder on the door got their
attention
and i as they were opening the door i
could see smoke
coming out of the air vents in that room
there were a lot of people up and
going up and down the hallways meanwhile
firefighters like stanley grisman's kiss
ran inside there were there were never
any fires like it of course
you know that was pretty pretty dramatic
chris manoski has cleared the 17th and
23rd floors
he came across bodies in the rooms and
hallways
there were so many dead people right at
the elevators
that i had to move creating a path to
help people escape to the roof and
get air lifted out by helicopters
there's the helicopter
his wife becky also seen the bodies
later that evening
there were a bunch of them by the
registration desk
and they were literally burned
to death in a motion like running
the former criminal investigator at the
district attorney's office probed the
fire
looking for building code violations to
determine county liability
it was that's terrible and you know you
don't ever forget that
a burning memory with a keepsake a
gaming chip
similar to lombardos just a few items
that remain from that day
on the strip kristen drummond 8 news now
and that fire four decades ago led to
various safety reforms including fire
sprinklers and other safety measures
becoming standard
we'll look at the improvements and the
changes that stem from this event coming
up tonight at six